aged women
and Kerry Wood on a late offering you
with the films that that you're pitching
now the ones that you're seeking
financing more how many of those have
you actually written yourself have you
ran another all mine through all those
homes yeah those are all much but one of
them has been written by eight years ago
it just kind of got fine like wine pain
pain I can help that story like in
2001-2002 I mean where do you find the
time to do everything that you're doing
day like you I don't you were writing
all these films or you're producing and
you're directing yeah I mean I'm just
I'm just I'm a filmmaker don't make it
finds ways to make films and I don't
have a full-time job this is my
full-time job I've created my situation
to where I can work for Dale steli still
entertainment 24 hours a day and it took
me eight years to create the situation
and this is why i am now i wake up read
a script right 10 20 pages you know go
to edit bay you know check out on
blockbuster make sure my stuff it's on a
shelf but my world is based on working
for myself and i have a team of people
as well that kind of help you know pick
up the slack here and there but i'm not
i mean my thing is if you want to make
it in this business you have to own your
own product if i'm gonna be spinning my
wheels jumping through hoops and loops
on scripts you best believe it's gonna
be for my script for